Anat, thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Happy to be here.
Thanks for having me.
This is so so great.
We met. I can't believe it was like
five years ago.
I think when I sat
on like a teenage entrepreneur
side of the table and pitched this idea,
which is actually about dietary restrictions,
which is why
we're gonna have a great time talking
about your new startup.
Way too many things to even give
about your bio,
but just as a quick introduction.
You know, founder of the Meet Program
which will I'd love to know more about.
Investment partner at
Innovation Endeavors,
one of the most remarkable
venture capital funds in the world.
And we both know Dror
and I get so much inspiration from
just seeing the strategy that all of you
have built out and the investments
you've made over there.
And now, you went back to being
a founder which many would say -
Definitely not the typical route.
Anat, you know,
let's just start from the back.
Meet. It is such a unique program
and with so much impact
that we have to give it first.
Sure.
I have to say actually,
I'm so happy also starting it
because you can’t ignore
what’s going on outside today.
So, for me, as you know we
both come from a place
where conflict and kind of ethnic strike
has been a part of our life
and history and every moment
and Meet definitely originated
in our effort to solve it.
So, just to say what is.
You know, it's a non-profit
that we started in 2004.
I started it with my brother
and one of our best friends
in 2 other Palestinian women,
and the idea was really to solve
the Israeli-Palestine conflict
or have an impact on it
by creating a network
of future leaders.
And we do it by bringing
excelling youth on both sides
to a really rigorous three-year program
and an alumni program
where they get taught
by an instructors from MIT
and Google and Facebook
and many many other companies.
And they learn computer science and
entrepreneurship and leadership
and kind of really
build initiatives together.
And the goal is for them
to become political, social
changemakers in their community.
To really change the status quo.
Incredible.
So, you actually are looking
at this conflict and saying,
Yeah, so there's a lot of things
that are happening on the top level
of decision makers,
but actually, why don't we take
a more bottom-up approach
and let's target those that are
going to be the next leaders,
and maybe if we can spark
some curiosity
and some liberal thinking
and open mindedness early on,
we can see great things happening.
Yeah. And I think you know,
again think about what's going on
in our world right now,
it's really about the
human connection, the humanity.
It's being able to understand
that even when someone is
totally different from you,
and you have perceptions
that we all have commonalities
and identities. And can we connect
around those places first.
And if you think about your experience,
probably at Stanford,
you know definitely my experience,
it's one of the things that hooked us
and led us to start Meet.
It's the networks in our lives
that change the way we look
at the world.
Right I always call 'em like the glasses
in which you see the world,
so if you suddenly met,
I call it like the newspaper test.
You know one of my best friends
in my masters was from Chile.
I never read an article
before I met her about Chile,
but suddenly I became really curious
had a lot of knowledge.
So, this is very much simplifying the idea.
Can it solve the Israeli-Palestine conflict
through that? You can start to bind
and create commonalities
and break down the barriers
and we do it also focusing
on young leaders
thinking that the impact model
is really putting people later on
in powerful positions who understand
the benefits of working together
and actually have the active network.
Right? Because it's those networks,
they don’t only change how you see
the world, but they are your tools
for making an impact. Right?
It’s like, when you see a problem,
the first thing you think about is,
"Who do I know that knows,
that can help me solve this?"
And when Israelis and Palestinians
never get to interact,
do not know each other,
they don't have each other.
And you know, in each other
they don't exist in each other’s
professional and social networks
and we're really breaking that.
I've lost you?
There. No we're back
Good we can edit this.
And I have to say,
and it speaks so truly to me.
You know, coming in to Stanford.
I did grow up on the line
between Palo Alto and Tel Aviv
but honestly it was the same type
of people. And you don't
really get to introduced
to the whole world,
and all of a sudden
my best friend here on road trip with me,
Santiago is from Mexico,
and he invites to be with him
and his family in their house.
And I'm seeing this whole new culture.
This amazing culture that
it doesn’t matter
how much I would have read,
I wouldn’t have been able
to really empathize with. And then,
the roommate who lives in front of me
in the dorms is from Uganda.
And he got a laptop
when he was younger
and he self-taught himself
how to program.
And he got to Stanford.
And he's talking about these
atrocities that are happening.
And hearing it from a primary source,
and one of my goals is now to go
and visit him and live with his family
in Uganda.
Because of what you're saying
that this human connection
and being there,
not just reading about it
as a second hand source,
but being there is remarkable.
Anat, skipping away
to Innovation Endeavors
because we only have 20 minutes.
It's impossible. I know. I know.
I should have done it a bigger -
Why couldn’t I have called it
a 30-minute leaders?
I don’t know why.
Innovation Endeavors.
Tell me a little bit about that
and what you did over there.
Yeah. So, first of all
Innovation Endeavors is
I agree with you
it's one of the most incredible
venture capital firms
who are out there to date.
Was originally started as a fund
that was solely backed by Eric Schmidt
from Google and was the founding partner
was Dror Berman
who's a very good friend of mine.
An amazing guy.
And the fund has grown significantly.
There’s a lot of other investors today.
And really, it is an example of
how you can use capital
to target big massive problems.
Massive problems.
So, actually Innovation never says
"We only tackle massive problems
Are you moving the needle?
If not, maybe we're not
the right partner for you"
That's right.
Massive problems that honestly
have a positive impact on the world.
So, not to confuse this with
social impact but really looking
at the places where you can
leverage technology to really shift
the game in either old markets
or emerging markets
in ways that contribute
to solving significant things in the world.
And for me you know,
it was an incredible journey to be able
to be part of that.
So you know, break this down for me
a little bit more because you know,
as an entrepreneur and as somebody
who gets excited so much
about this world,
it gets confusing sometimes.
It gets confusing because a lot of people
love to say that they're gonna make
an impact.
Some of them mean social impact.
Some of them global impact.
Financial impact.
What are the differences
and how has Innovation Endeavors
placed itself as the nucleus
of changing the world?
Look, I mean you can measure impact
in many different ways.
By the way, even if ...
you look at the individual impact
you look at a human scale
how many human lives have we impacted
You look at economic job creation
or economic impact.
You look at solutions
to health problems like disease,
or the environment and so on.
And I think for a venture capital firm
like Innovation Endeavors,
you look for that intersection
where, and this is not about
a double bottom line or triple,
but it is about that intersection
where deep tech can significantly
shift the way things are done
in a way that also generates returns
but that can really create solutions
and create a better world.
You know, the question of
how you think about that?
It really depends.
At the end of the day -
That's the innovation side of it.
What?
Yes. And what you believe
are models for change.
You know I've talked over the years,
and myself I've transitioned from
non-profit to public sector.
Worked in the public sector.
I've worked in VC.
I'm now an entrepreneur.
You know, there are very different
models of impact.
But I think it’s the choice,
you make choices about
what are the problems you're trying
to solve, who are the people
you are trying to influence,
what kind of teams you build
and cultures you build,
and all of that is part of what you can
think about as impact.
Did I lose you again?
And so, at the end
the question yields itself.
You can’t be an expert on everything.
You're a small team.
Innovation Endeavors is a small team.
And when you're dealing with you know these,
with the most difficult problems
in the world to solve, you kind of need
to be an expert on them to solve them.
So how do you even go about
being a partner in this? A capital partner
but also you know sitting on these,
the Boards of these companies,
or even just understanding whether
this is a viable business that could
actually reach that impact.
Yeah, I mean again.
Although, and I have to say
you know I'm no longer a partner
I'm now on the other side,
but I can speak from the experience
when I was there.
And I'm also super lucky
because Innovation Endeavors
invested in my company,
is on my board so I get to stay very
Yes yes and I can't wait to go ... it, yep.
Yes and I love so much.
But just kind of my perspective.
When I was more on the VC side,
as part of what I loved was this challenge
that every minute of the day
you're learning a new space.
At the same time there's definitely
verticals that you start to build thesisis
around and you understand
and kind of deep dive in to. In addition,
it's really about building networks again
of experts around you.
Whether its founders or other people
that you can learn from quickly.
It's learning how do you understand
the things as quickly as possible
and are able to target the main risk
and have a thesis about
whether this risk can be kind of
de-risk by this team. This team
and this company is the right team
to de-risk if the opportunity is
big enough. I would say
third is experience
over time as a VC. You know,
VCs like to say
it's a mix of an art and a science.
There's something to it.
You know each person develops
their intuitive and instinct.
Some of it gets a little bit
on the bias side. But at the same time,
you also develop certain approaches,
frameworks, questions that really help you
asses those things pretty analytically.
No no I love it. That's just incredible.
And Anat, I hope I'll have
enough time for this
but now you're actually on
maybe one of the most exciting
parts of the journey
being on the entrepreneur side.
Co-founding a company,
not just another company
but a needle moving company
that Innovation Endeavors
and Khosla ventures, and Marc Benioff,
Benioff is also a part of.
Please, what is Ukko?
What is that name actually?
Everyone ask. So Ukko,
it's actually Ukko.
it's the Finnish from Finland.
It's the God of harvesting rains
of the Finnish mythology.
And we wanted a name
that is not overly bio,
is connected to what we do,
which I'll explain in a sec,
and also had some kind of
personal connection. I grew up
going to Finland in the summers.
I have a really close relationship
with that country. So, Ukko
we're an early stage bio-tech company
with focus on solving food allergy
and sensitivities.
So, things like gluten sensitivities,
and also peanut allergy,
and other food allergies. And we go about it -
And now did
you really just say that you're working
to solve food allergies
like gluten sensitivities
and peanuts sensitivity?
That's right.
I mean, these are like that's huge.
Like you know, some people say,
"I wanna sell more ads.
I want to have people
download my app on the app store"
You're solving food, things that are
killing people around the world.
That's right. And I have to say,
you know for me going back
to Innovation Endeavors,
definitely you know something
that's super close to my heart.
I don't think I would have ever left
unless it was for something like this.
And as I said, ...
Yes. So, food allergy.
You know I don’t remember this growing up,
and I grow up like I'm an
in-between person. I grew up in Israel
and the US, I don’t remember
having allergies around me.
Right. People didn't really talk
about them even.
And it just wasn’t as prevalent.
So, the data’s astounding.
There’s been like
a 50% rise in kids with food allergies
in the past decade alone.
We work with the best best doctors
literally in the world. And I'll also tell you
that it's not clear why this is happening.
There are certain explanations
but none of them are,
there isn’t one resounding scientifically
backed explanation.
So, yes, we are targeting,
we basically design proteins that are
totally safe but maintain all the
other qualities and we apply them
in the food world
and the therapeutics world.
So, both creating new types of foods
and also drugs.
So, what is the vision for this?
You're saying you're literally creating
these different sources of proteins that are
gonna be used in creating foods
that we consume so that somebody
who now couldn’t eat a cake
because of their gluten sensitivity,
they'll be able to eat that same cake
because the protein structure is different?
Yeah. What's your favorite bakery
there in Israel that you miss the most?
Or like in San Francisco California?
I'm a simple guy.
I go for like Arcaffe for lunch there.
Okay. So, let's go Tartine
in San Francisco, okay.
So, imagine being able to walk into Tartine
in San Francisco and being able
to eat anything that you want there.
It would be safe for anyone with
Celiac or
gluten sensitivity
Today for people with gluten sensitivities
you know really the only thing you can do is
avoid the food by eating gluten free.
Gluten free is that, not very tasty.
Actually, the main issue's their often
very unhealthy because you have to add
a lot of substitutes to compensate
for the fact that there is no gluten.
So, yes. For example, with gluten,
our gluten proteins are completely safe
but maintain all the other qualities
so you have that amazing breads,
pastas, pizza doughs that anyone
in the world could eat
would be safe for everyone.
And on the food allergy side,
we're actually developing a drug
that would be a potential cure.
Wow. Okay so the completely
yet intertwined things.
Both of them world changing.
And at the end, I guess
the biggest challenge of it would be
to make this economically viable.
So, that the producing gluten free pasta
that is just as tasty as the same.
I'm not even talking about the challenges
of getting an FDA approval for a cure
and that sort of thing.
So, is this really the biggest challenge?
Or what are you finding now
as you're going through this
entrepreneurship path?
I mean, the entrepreneurship path
has so many challenges.
You know, but that question of
like what keeps you up at night?
On most regular nights
not during pandemics and you know
really civil unrest that
is so concerning and saddening.
But I would say,
you know definitely making sure
that we have a good go to market.
We are a bio tech company.
Biology is a tough partner in the route
because you can’t control it
sometimes as much as,
It's not like if you hack all night
or code all night you can get it out
and kind of you know launch and iterate.
Often it takes time,
experiments take time and so on.
So, for us making sure that we,
the minute that our product
gets out there
it's truly safe and wonderful
and provides a solution for
these communities that’s critical.
We're actually producing our gluten
through other crops
so it'll end up being, cost
a very price you know, competitive.
That's just incredible.
Anat, give me a few insights on this path
that you are going on as an entrepreneur.
So really the things that do
keep you up at night.
And I mean, you're a mother,
you have different responsibilities.
You did the VC job.
A lot of people are comparing
it, that you're having a lot of the fun
that an entrepreneur might have
but you still get to do your
nine to five job and go have dinner
with the kids every day and all.
Maybe not. Well Innovation Endeavors ...
But now you're committed to this
you know seven to nine-year journey
at least of running this company.
And how was this decision?
And how did it actually work out?
For me, first of all it was hard
cause I left something I loved
and I'm again lucky to have maintained
it also in my life.
But I'm also an operator.
There's a big difference in your
daily experiences you see as you
may experience and kind of the
daily experience on the operating side.
I love the operation.
I especially love the zero to something.
Those are my favorite things
to kind of get involved in.
So you know, it’s very different
as far as you definitely dive deep
versus in a VC you go wide. Right?
Like as I said, every two hours
you may deal ... company.
You get the really macro view of the world
whereas for me now
I'm deep deep diving into our world.
So that's one difference.
And you know you have to,
there's the multitasking is a mess.
At MIT where I went you know there’s a,
they'll say that freshman year is like
drinking from the fire hose.
So, I think especially being a CEO,
it’s like drinking from I don’t know,
50 firehoses going on at once.
Every minute of the day
I'm really trying to figure out
am I prioritizing the right thing?
Is this really what I should be working on
because it’s all the time
you cannot get everything done.
And when you add on to that small kids,
that price only become you know
that struggle only becomes more difficult
or a bigger challenge.
Amazing. Anat, I can’t believe
our time is almost over.
But I have two more questions.
First of all, this is a very selfish question
because I now have you
giving me your attention and I'm on my own
entrepreneurship path.
From the idea to the amazing unit
that I really enjoyed being in.
To now at Stanford and
I'm exploring these different paths
from venture capital to technology to
entrepreneurship. And I imagine that
there’s a lot of like minded people
that are going through these similar
dilemmas of where do we prioritize?
And you know, careers are no longer linear.
And I take so much inspiration
from the path that you chose
and from a lot of your friends that chose.
And what would be your
best recommendation
or recommendations you would give
to somebody like me who's really
just starting out their path
and has much much to learn
and many ways to go?
Yeah. I would say first of all I think
I'm definitely an example
of connecting the dots and
I'm still connecting it. You know,
my background's very very
interdisciplinary and really went from
one place to another.
And I think one of things I learn,
a few things I've learned,
one is don't stay in your head too long.
There's a limit to how much you can plan.
A lot happens by doing.
You discover a lot of new things
about your passions,
about what you really connect to,
what you care about
by getting out there and
starting to do things.
You can't plan the path.
It's never gonna be the way
you planned it exactly.
You sometimes have to jump
and go and just keeps thinking
how it leads you forward.
People tend, especially when
they're in school,
to kind of really try to figure out,
consult with a million people
and you get locked in sometimes.
And sometimes you just have to
take the risk and move forward
and know that you're not just
picking one path.
It'll diverge along the way
to other things as well.
Totally. Okay. And very very last
I half warned about this ahead of time.
But still, I want to know one, two
maybe three words that you would
consider yourself as or maybe your kids
would consider you as.
Or if I would ask Dror,
or your co-founder at Ukko,
who is Anat? What drives you?
What are the key thing
that keeps you up?
I don’t if it’s the key thing
that keeps me up. But I'd say, yeah.
When you told me you may ask this,
the reason is, first, I would say
I'm still figuring that out.
I realize at some point in my life that.
That's the best answer I ever got. Anat.
You know, a long time ago
I kept looking for definitions
and actually realized I don’t want that.
It's a dynamic question.
So, I don’t have one answer.
I can also say that I realize
I'm really an in between. I'm an in between
person in so many things.
I'm Israeli but I'm also American.
You know I'm an entrepreneur.
I'm a mom. And that's actually a strength.
It's also a struggle because you have to
balance and figure out
and feel okay in uncertainty
and your identity and so on
So I don’t know.
Hopefully that gives you
a little bit of what you wanted.
I love it. Anat, toda raba.
Thank you so much. Best of luck.
And just keep inspiring me and others
Please.
Thanks.
Take care.
All right. Bye.